جماهير نادي اشبيليا تغزو شوارع العاصمه
المجاريه بودابست
نيمار يثير غضب اداره باريس مجددا
يكشف كوالي سراحيل بيكي عن برشلونه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
وصلت جماهير اشبيليه الى العاصمه المجريه
التي تحتضن اليوم الاربعاء انهاء البطوله
المفضله لديهم بطوله الدوري الاوروبي
ويلتقي اشبيليه صاحب الرقم القياسي للفوز
بالمسابقه مع نظيره روما ومن المنتظر ان
يساند نحو 12 الف مشجع نادي اشبيليه على
ملعب بوشكا شارينا وهو اكبر تنقل لجماهير
الفريق الاندلسي في نهائي مسابقه اوروبيه
ويخوض لعب ويست هام اولا نهائي اوروبي
للفريق منذ 43 عاما حين يواجهون فيورنتينا
في نهائي دوري المؤتمر الاسبوع المقبل لعب
المدرب ديفيد مويز فضلوا الذهاب لمدينه
للالعاب المائيه في منتجعا بالبرتغال حيث
نشر اللاعبون صورا للرحله عبر حساباتهم
على السوشيال ميديا بينما
فضلانز الاستعداد للنهائي بلعب الجولف تحت
اشعه الشمس
وضع نيمار اداره سان جيرمان في موقف محرج
بعد تغيب عن احتفالات الفريق بتتويج بلقب
الدوري الفرنسي وكانت قال تيم مدرب الفريق
قد صرح بان غياب نيمار المصاب كان بسبب
بعد المسافه بين باريس ومدينه تروى لكن
النجم البرازيلي نشر صورا له في جائزه
موناكو الكبرى ليس هذا فقط بل بدا مستمتعا
بوقته والتقط صورا مع نجم فيلم سبايدر مان
توم هولاند
بعد اعتزال بيكيا المفاجئ شهر نوفمبر
الماضي خرج تشافي مدرب برشلونه يروي
تفاصيل اقناع مدافع بلوغران السابق بترك
الملاعب وقلت تشافي في مقابله تلفزيونيه
لانه لم ينام خلال الليله التي ابلغ فيها
بيكي بضروره الاعتزال بسبب العلاقه بسبب
علاقه الصداقه التي تربطه مع بيكي مضيفا
بين الدول الاسباني السابق تقابل الامر في
النهايه وتفاهم بان ايام عمل فريق قد
انتهت وهو ما حدث ايضا مع جوردي الباسكتس
[موسيقى]